Speaker 1: The other bizarre thing that happened
this weekend or when the weekend started on Friday
was the more full picture that we saw of the
attack on Paul Pelosi, Nancy Pelosi's husband.
And again, not going to play
the tape. The brutal attack,
the hammer attack on the nearly
octogenarian Paul Pelosi by David the pap.
And David Pap. The day that the footage was
released made a phone call to a reporter at KTVU
and wanted to say sorry. Now i'm going
to read how ktvu categorized the call.
And they're going to play the call, the segment
of the call that they've put that they've
made public. And it is remarkable. That the the
conspiracy theories that were promoted by people
like Megyn Kelly and elsewhere, that there was all
kinds of conspiracies surrounding the relationship
that Paul Pelosi had with this this guy, which
didn't exist. And then when we see it, rather than
have a mea culpa moment, rather than them come out
and say, Oh, we're really sorry, we were wrong. Of
course, that's not what they do. But this is this
is this call is remarkable because it leads to,
again, when Republicans and conservatives use
the words talking about liberty and talking about
tyranny, they do so knowing that it doesn't just
happen in a vacuum. They do so knowing that people
like David Pap and others who who exert violence
in in some attempts to overthrow the government
or make a change, they know that their words don't
go forth void, that there is an endgame and some
people are going to latch on to that language,
to that rhetoric and make violence happen.
Here's here's the description from ktvu.
David papp called the the ktvu newsroom
this afternoon. And told our reporter
he had an important message. He said he
attacked paul pelosi because people's individual
liberties are under attack. In the chilling call,
he apologized for not going further. The call
came on the same day of the video of the infamous
hammer attack on paul pelosi was released. Here
is that excerpt from the call. And then I want
to talk about that rhetoric once again.
Speaker 3: Okay. So what's what? What do
you want to say? Because they released as you
know, they released the video earlier today.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I saw that.
Speaker 3: Yes. What what did
you want? Thank you for calling me. What
did you want? What did you want to tell me?
Speaker 4: Nothing. All of the body
cameras have an important, important
message for everyone in America.
You're welcome. Liberty isn't dying. It's
being killed systematically and deliberately.
The people killing it have names and addresses.
They got their names and addresses so I could pay
them a little visit. I have a heart to heart chat
about their bad behavior. Liberty needs watering.
You've got to sell the Patriots and put their own
lives on the line. In opposition directions. I
would also like to apologize. I want to apologize
to everyone. I messed up, but I didn't really bad.
I'm so sorry I couldn't get more of them. It's
my own fault. No one else to blame. Actually, I'm
better prepared. I spent all my time exposing
government corruption online, only to have them
silence quickly as they could. It circumvented
the Constitution private industry. But the looming
class, of course, is the repression of your civil
rights and private industry. It's called fascism.
I don't know what more to say. I had a website
of over 300 pages. That's 300 pages of stuff
they don't want to hear. I'm in the process of
trying to set up a new site out of the reach
of tyrannical fascists, fascist Internet censors.
Speaker 1: Many of you know I grew up in a white,
Christian nationalist household. That was
my faith tradition. I grew up in northern
Idaho amidst the separatist types, militia type
people. At the very least, people who admired the
militiaman. And this language was all over the
place growing up. And that line there that you
might not be familiar with when him talking
about the Tree of Liberty needs watering.
There's a quote somewhere about the the Tree of
Liberty needing watered by the blood of patriots.
And he's referring there to. He didn't go far
enough. He didn't he didn't attack or kidnap,
which was his plan. Nancy Pelosi. MOORE He didn't.
He should have done more people. He should have
attacked more people. And for him, this is the
watering of the Tree of Liberty, giving up his
freedom to a larger cause. And this language that
Republicans use, that conservative use, the Ted
Cruz's, the Mac Gates's the Paul Gosar, the the
entire Freedom Caucus, they all talk like this
and they know what the result is, that it's going
to whip up a certain percentage of the audience
of their fan base in the court who are going to
take matters into their own hands. They're not
going to sit idly by while their country is being
destroyed. They're going to do something about
it. Of course, I say country being destroyed
tongue in cheek, because that is not at all
what's happening. They have been convinced of
election fraud on a wide conspiracy laden basis.
And if your country is being taken from you,
if it's being invaded at the southern border
and nothing's being done, you take matters
into your own hands. Or at least they do.
This is all dangerous. But you're not going to
see Republicans change their messaging. You're
not going to see them change their ways because
it works for them. The results don't matter to
them. The violence that is brought upon innocent
people doesn't matter to them. The insurrections
that have happened in the past and that may come
to pass again, don't matter to Republicans. They
don't matter. Because power is what matters.
As long as they stay in office, as long as
they're able to try to implement and continue
to implement a usurpation of our constitutional
rights. The women's right to choose marriage
equality. A host of other civil liberty issues.
They're going to keep at it. It is. It is it is
time for America and well intended, country loving
liberals to swarm the polls because the only way
that this is going to change is through activism
and organization to overwhelm them at the at the
polling station. That is is what it's going to do.
Because we are obviously not going to be using
the same violence inducing tactics that they do.